hello everyone while I'm preparing the
1971 candidates matches I thought I'd
show you a nice game I played between
Magnus Carlsen and Fabiano Khurana it
was played in 2011 bill chess first of
all the 2018 bills Jazz Festival just
finished you all know that Sharma media
of one that would a two-point lead ahead
of Magnus Carlsen but this is 2011 hints
and it's I think it's the fourth game
the two of them ever played so as as as
a preparation for the upcoming World
Chess Championship that will take place
in November I thought it'd be a nice
touch to show at this game but before we
do it
we do have a nice photo challenge so
there you have it it's a photo by Elaine
Pringle who is the gentleman in this
photo it's a very nice photo one might
even say a smooth photo but yeah best of
luck to everyone and before we show this
game we do have a couple of Statistics
you some of you might be interested in
this this is the current score between
the two of them if you consider only
classical games Magnus Carlsen beat
Fabiano Caruana
at 10 to 5 with 17 draws and if you
include the rapid and exhibition games
then cross and beat Fabiano caruana 23
to 11 with 21 rows and if you include
only rapid and exhibition games cross
and beat Caruana
13 to 6 with four draws now if you
regardless of which time for me you
consider a cross and is still in the
lead but you know that's all matters
very little it only matters how they
will play in November and as although I
know all of you really enjoyed the
ratings here is a list of the live
readings so across and still in first
place it's not all that different since
the top 10 players aside from cross and
mammoth Europe did not play my media
I've had a had a magnificent boost of
+16 after winning the bill chess
festival which two points ahead of
Magnus Carlsen so there we have it
cousin number one in ratings and Caruana
number two in ratings so it will
definitely be a nice a nice match as
you'll remember when cousin faced Anand
he was rated
almost
a hundred points above Ireland so now
this is a pretty equal in ratings and
here we have of course the 2018 World
Chess Championship logo so there we have
it for those of you who perhaps haven't
seen it this is it this is what they
came up with so you know I'd like you to
pause the video here just for a couple
of seconds and write the first thing
that pops into your mind in in the
comments when you see this magnificent
piece of work
so that being said let's check out the
game as you as you all know the game at
the match in November will consist of
twelve games after that they will go
probably into sin two tiebreaks I like
there were one cousin faced kurakin in
2016 and then probably if it will be a
draw after everything then probably an
Armageddon game but I don't know to me
it seems pretty silly to decide the
world chess champion by an Armageddon
game but you have to decide it somehow
it will be played between 9th and 28th
of November in London like we said and
if someone doesn't mind playing in
London it's definitely Carlsen as
perhaps you remember from our 2013
candidate series in in London in subway
place it was Magnus cross and who won
the 2013 candidates tournament before he
faced Vishwanathan Anand for the title
so that being said let's check out this
game Carlson has the white pieces and he
opens with E 4 we have E 5 Knight to f3
Knight to c6 d4 and it captures on d4 we
have Knight captures on d4 and now
Bishop to c5 here Knight captures on c6
by Carlsen this you can also go for
something like 3/3 also a standard wine
after Queen f6 with a triple attack here
simply c3 and then black has a variety
of options Carlsen goes for the early
exchange Knight captures on c6 and
karana plays Abby captures on c6 also
possible of course is Queen to f6 with
the immediate threat of checkmate on f2
and then after white defense and black
will simply recapture D captures and the
game continues but here B captors on c6
and Bishop to d3
we have Queen to h4 already Khurana is
threatening checkmate here so Queen to
e2 crossing defense checkmate Knight to
e7 and now Knight to c3 corona castles
Bishop to e3 cousin offers a trade of
Bishops now Bishop to b6 offering a you
know inviting Carlsen to capture on b6
where karana would either fix his pawn
structure or perhaps create a semi-open
a file we have castles and now comes d5
so black was able to push d5 the bishop
is now ready to be developed the like
the lights were bishop and always well
for black eke after Sun d5 Knight
captures on d5 threatening to win the
bishop pair so Carson moves the bishop
bishop to d2 we have push up to d4 and
now rook 81 and here you might think I
move like Bishop to g4 is a very nice
move as it brings a and I a nice light
square bishop into the game with tempo
the queen is under attack but here which
Queen to b4 you would pressure this h7
phone ok for now it's defended by the
Queen but a lot of things can happen the
bishop on d4 is under attack your if the
bishop moves you have to move to f6 now
f3 after white pushes f3 the bishop will
also be protecting the Queen here but
you know there's no reason for for black
to allow this for example knife captures
captures captures white wins upon and if
black wants to win the pawn back then
white will have I could have a nice lead
in development so here Caruana plays a
better move Knights to be for going
after Carlson's light square bishop and
here Colson finds a very nice way that
prevents Caruana from winning the bishop
there from you know not allowing Carlsen
to have the bishop very anymore Queen to
e for attacking Coronas undefended Queen
here so corona captures we have Queen
captures and now Bishop captures on e4
brush up to a6 attacking the rook nice
to eat to blocking of course you cannot
you know put put a bishop on d3 as d 3
square is attacked by the bishop and by
denied so nice to e2 only move
attacking the bishop on d4 Bishop to c5
and now comes a three we have Knight
back to d5 before is coming Bishop to d6
and here a very nice move it's very hard
to find a plan here for white blacks
plan is simple he wants to put this as a
broken da he wants to put this rock on
yet his bishops are are very nice here
so what do you do here for white
I really would enjoy it if you pause the
video here and try to find a nice move
for white it's the engines favorite move
is the Carson plate and perhaps you will
you will find this move as well so I
will give it a couple of seconds as
usual for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations you just found the
top engine recommendation and the move
Carson played in this game and for those
of you who just want to enjoy show the
move is nice to d4 here it seems like
there's nothing to do here as you can't
really move the knight of course your
rook would be hanging you can't move the
rook the rook seems to be protecting the
night here and e2 so everything seems to
be connected but Carson displayed he
plays a knight to d4 offers a look on f1
so there's really no better move than to
simply capture the rock which Caruana
plays Bishop captures we have King
captures and now comes Knight back to b6
if you play something like nice to e7 to
keep an eye on this pawn doesn't really
help you Knight captures Knight captures
Bishop captures the rookin a8 is under
attack and this is kind of the whole
point of the of the the exchange
sacrifice after rook moves Bishop 2 c1
now not allowing any any discoveries
after this Bishop moves but now you can
see that the light-square bishop is
guarding the eight square and it will be
actually Carlson who will be controlling
the file and the bishop pair and the
control of the e-file will be
compensation enough for the exchange
so after King F 1 we have 9th to b6 and
mountain Knight captures on c6
rook F to e8 and now another beautiful
move by Carlsen
we have a 4 a 4 is an excellent move
because if you capture
here knife characters on a four you get
nice to e7 check opening up a discovered
attack from the bishop to the rock on a8
rook captures and now Bishop captures an
a8 we have rook captures Bishop captures
and here after Knight to b6 attacking
the bishop and Bishop to c6 it would be
a MIDI material would be cool but
Carlson would enjoy a bishop pair
against the bishop and the night where
Carlson would have to pawn islands and
the corona would have three point
Islands so with a better pawn structure
and the bishop pair Carlson would enjoy
a nice advantage here so after a four
King to f8 by Caruana
and now comes a five kicking the night
we have Knight to c4 attacking the
bishop and now comes Bishop to c1 a six
and here cousin played f4 this is a
beautiful move
it's a beautiful move because it really
creates a very complex you know the
position is beautiful here
unfortunately for Caruana he did not
fully grasp this f4 move because he
could have continued the fight here
there is a very nice move corona played
rook to e6 which is a blunder that loses
the game but feel free to pause the
video here and try to find a move
Caruana missed it's a very nice tactical
shot that allows him to keep on playing
this game so once again I will give it a
couple of seconds for those of you who
are interested in maybe finding this
nice tactical shot for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations you
are an excellent tactician and for those
who just want to enjoy the show
Knight to III check it's a very nice
idea of course now if you move the king
then rook captures Bishop on e4 as the
knight is preventing the roof from
defending the bishop if you capture
night with the bishop then again you can
capture this bishop with the rook and of
course if you capture with the rook
then comes a bishop captures an f4
attacking the rook and the bishop and
now you have to move the rook and give
up the bishop for example rook f3 now
comes the bishop captures on c1 and
after you move the bishop bishop d5 to
attack the f7 pawn f6 is coming and the
black is still up the exchanger but with
so much pressure from white it would be
still be a drawn drawn position
where a lot of things can happen but the
fight continues here unfortunately for
Caruana after f4 he did not fully
understand the meaning of this f4 move
and he played rook to e6 so once again
tried to punish this move try to
understand why f4 was such an important
move and once again pause the video here
for the third time in this video not
counting the feed a logo and you don't
try to refute Kerwin as idea so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you have paused the
video for the third time and for those
who just want to enjoy the show Bishop
to b5 of course is the move and now you
see the problem even after even if you
capture any one team captures even after
rook to e8 check and and the king moves
king you have to now you see that the
bishop is guarding all the squares the
knight can jump to this point is
guarding b6 that the knight can jump to
and now you see the full meaning of the
f4 now a pawn move the pawn is now
guarding the e5 square and the knight
cannot go back to e5 so Khurana missed
this so it does really matter if he
captures anyone he played rook to f6 6
he tried to trick cousin I would the
idea that if cousin captures the knight
then he can play better characters on f4
and after Bishop captures rook captures
with check King moves he will capture
here and our black would be winning
because two rooks are better than a rock
and the night but after this rook to
have six move cross and simply played
rook to e4 and now there are no more
tricks
it was in this position that Fabiano
caruana resigned in the game so the f4
pawn is nicely protected twice by the
rook and by the by the bishop there are
normal no more moves here no more tricks
next move cross and will simply grab the
knight and c4 or Caruana can simply give
it up for a pawn but you know it's all
the same a winning position for Carlsen
so that's the game I do hope you enjoyed
it it's from the 2000 2011 bill chess
festival which Carlsen one with a
two-point lead
much like char here mommy DRF won it in
2018 but with 2-point lead ahead of
Magnus Carlsen
how will the match in
remember look like we'll just have to
wait you know a couple more a couple
more days well like something less than
100 days to fully enjoy it and hopefully
it will it will be a bit more exciting
than the course and cardigan match but
you know who can tell what will happen
so once again I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank sorry about that I
would like to thank Michael Acevedo Paul
weebs Karthik Sri Ranga Michael Cassidy
and Albert Slayers for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here think all for
watching and I will see you soon
tomorrow with the 1971 candidates
matches thank you all and I'll see you
soon